my fellow good humans before you watch
this video you know that everything we
do is for human good one way we also
wanted to push our message out to the
world was through our March mm-hmm so we
only have a couple hundred of these left
just a few hundred good human l a good
human calm I believe this is a little
lighter because he washed it so many
times but I love it I can look this it's
amazing anyways enjoy the video and
we'll see you guys on the inside yeah
yeah I teach in higher education and I
still don't think most people should go
and higher education and I know this
because I failed these students like at
the end the semester I give them a so if
I don't like some students I like all
students so where would I go you like
everything you student so you'd be over
here okay okay I'm sorry I'm so how look
at this question is I may not like the
students behavior but I'd like all
students I just don't like the behavior
and I think if you frame it like that
then students to feel like I can change
because they think they are the behavior
then they feel like I'm a bad person
then I can't change no no you're a good
person the behavior that you're
exhibiting isn't that something that I
don't like I don't even think of it the
bad bad so in so-called bastion
sometimes those are the ones I like the
most
those are the ones that be my friends
I'm talking I think about this song so
called good students who I might not
necessarily like yeah they don't know I
don't like them cuz I don't make it
obvious like some students have come up
and they'll be like you're my favorite
teacher I love you and I'm like oh my
god
I'm the product of low-income family and
you know when I was a kid I had to take
the bus through gang ridden areas of
areas that were arrivals with my the
area that I live in and where I grew up
and it was hard it was hard to
understand that school was a haven and I
learned that quick yeah I teach in a
low-income school very low-income and I
want them to do like the best they can
but obviously like if they come to
school and they didn't eat dinner and a
lot of my students like don't get fed at
home like I'm gonna be more
understanding why they don't want to do
work or if they're sleeping other than
like other kids who just like do that on
a regular basis especially with things
like homework that aren't that important
in the first place if they say like oh
my mom wasn't home because she had class
and then she had to go to work after
that and I stay with my grandma and she
only speaks Spanish then of course I'm
going to say okay you can have extra
time on your homework or it's okay if
you didn't turn it in today I guess my
take on leniency I think is sometimes
I'd look at its uttering like when it
comes to suspension rates I've seen it
where ministers are like well we don't
want to have a highest finish rate for
african-american students so let's lower
the standard we're gonna only give them
two days when it's something that they
should have been recommended for so if
our students already feel different
we're in like oh well they're gonna be
more lenient thing we're not going to do
as much even though baby and wife cynic
like soon did the same exact thing we're
gonna marry in lenient because of their
situation and it starts they'd be like
they're other people or they're other it
makes them feel a little bit nauseous
awesome
[Music]
we don't promote vocational schools as
much as we used to which we should
because being a plumber is a good job
like if you want to do that if you want
to be an electrician like I'm totally
for that I think they should choose what
they want to do yeah I teach in higher
education and I still don't think most
people should go and higher education
and I know that's because I failed these
students like at the end of semester I
give them ABS because they stopped
showing up after week two maybe you
should take the semester off
like maybe this is not the time for you
for a higher education right now so it's
not just some people who should or
should not be they'll some people who
maybe in this part in their life this is
not time yet and I think about that a
lot and especially come grading time
with how people are feeling and
sometimes you go to school and you feel
stressed because just yesterday you saw
the news and it said that there is a
shooting somewhere and all of a sudden
you're scared now what if that happens
at my school so I get the idea of
wanting to have a gun there I don't like
the idea of guns anyway for the
community in general so I can't say that
I think teachers should have them like I
thought of this elaborate idea how it's
gonna collect a bunch of huge rocks and
give one to each kid and have like wasp
spray and be like if anyone comes
everyone just throw your rock like I
don't think we need guns I think there's
so many alternatives a lot of guns get
stolen and I just don't want to open
that to anyone else yeah I really
wouldn't put my laptop to class fearing
I was gonna get us going teachers
already have enough stress in their
lives already and so you add on top of
that I got to control the classroom I
have a gun I'm not in a situation where
every day I know how okay I'm gonna
deescalate no I'm gonna be scared I'm
just shooting I don't know I just don't
want ya
Vince yeah I see a lot of principal shot
I'm only in somewhat because I am part
of a group of people that has underpaid
but I think in general people underpaid
and it goes back to fixing society in
general it's not like a priority to me
that teachers get paid more but I think
I would be lying if I said I get paid
for my services I worked the second job
this year I don't want to waste that
time outside of the classroom because
you know I could be planning for this
year I could be planning for next year
but unfortunately you know that's a
reality for some teachers especially
when it's just me I don't have a second
income in my household I'm the only one
earning income so I come from the arts
like small arts nonprofits so the fact
that I have a pension and decent
benefits is incredible so I feel
extremely lucky but I also know that I
have where I am because it's built on
the work of years of activism and unions
so I something I don't take for granted
[Music]
at my school a lot of times we get
students who have already been expelled
or suspended from other schools and of
course it depends on the situation if
they have a lot of instability in their
life it's probably just going to make it
worse I had a student as similar when
earlier in my teaching career I kicked
him out probably about 40% of the class
last day of school he's playing
basketball on my team and he breaks his
arm I have to take him into the hospital
this kid was Russian and his mother came
and the grandmother came none of them
spoke English he had to translate
everything this kid was silly every day
in my class come to find out his father
had died in a war he had to work after
school every day so when he came to my
class when he came to school that was
this time to relax you know because as
soon as he left he had to be a man he
had to be an adult and it haunts me and
I think about that I really understand a
kid's situation
[Music]
[Applause]
you